it's fair to say that being sold to is
for the most part annoying modern sales
and advertising is akin to that of a
pestering child constantly following us
around and trying to get us to do things
for it as annoying as this child might
be however its character appears to be
necessary in our modern consumer driven
world business owners need ways of
communicating their goods and services
to consumers and consumers need ways of
learning about in deciding what goods
and services to purchase arguably the
problem is not necessarily that we are
being sold - but what we are often being
sold and perhaps how more specifically
the tendency for businesses and
advertising to sell us things that we
don't truly want or need paired with
their ability to often convince us that
we do rewind several hundred years to
the late 17th century consumerism as we
know it takes form in various countries
of Europe during and following this time
a shifting in economic behaviors would
begin to unfold where individuals would
no longer buy and sell items strictly
around immediate needs like food simple
clothing items tools bowls and cups and
so on but rather goods that were focused
around the desire for luxury or
additional less necessary comforts
things like tobacco tea fashionable
clothing fancy wigs crafted furniture
high-end silverware and so on
fast-forward to the 19th century as a
result of increasing consumer markets
advertising is developed more formally
and utilized as a major economic force
generally during this time advertising
would provide consumers with basic
information about a product or service
in order to attend to the consumers
better judgements of rational decision
making
fast-forward another hundred years or so
to the 20th century specifically in
America advertising would begin to study
and use methods of human psychology with
this advertising would no longer be
driven by the features or information of
a product but more by the feelings
narratives and ideals that could be
created and associated with the product
in other words a soda advertisement
would no longer sell soda but the ideal
of happiness an alcohol ad would sell
alcohol
but the ideal of charisma or fun a car
ad wouldn't sell a car but the ideal of
social status and so on ever since this
strategy has remained mostly the
standard for all of modern marketing
renowned American linguist philosopher
and cognitive scientist Noam Chomsky has
been a longtime researcher and critic of
the role of modern consumerism and
advertising one specifically notable
idea and the one that we will primarily
be focusing on here is his view that in
the modern world rather than assisting
in higher more complex needs most
businesses and advertising work to
create and perpetuate useless and
frivolous needs for Chomsky commerce
focuses almost exclusively on the
trivial and superficial things like
vanity pleasure indulgence self
distraction and so on in this more
genuine and higher level human needs
like good mental and physical health
creative expression a sense of community
an opportunity for self-realization are
neglected for a better understanding of
this concept it is helpful to reference
the distinguished Russian psychologist
Abraham Maslow and his research and
theory on the nature of human needs
Maslow beautifully summarized his theory
on the spectrum of human needs with a
simple visual diagram of a pyramid
popularly known as Maslow's hierarchy of
needs within this diagram there are five
levels starting from the bottom at a
physiological level we require obvious
things like food and water moving up to
the next level we need safety and
security however beyond these two levels
Maslow suggested that we would begin to
enter into higher and more psychological
levels of needs first a sense of
belongingness and social connection then
a sense of esteem or respect and finally
at the top of it all a term that Maslow
coined as self-actualization in other
terms this essentially describes the
fulfillment of one's self and their full
potential of skills and abilities this
idea along with the diagram as a whole
coincides rather succinctly with the
suggestions of Chomsky like Maslow
Chomsky suggests that we require things
that attended the full hierarchy of our
needs the top being a sense of creative
self fulfillment
however the problem for both maslow and
Chomsky is found in the fact that most
businesses and products neglect the
higher levels of human needs and focus
far more on our unconscious base layers
because people I think what dignity and
a sense of self-worth and a sense of
courage creating and doing something
important that's what we are and I think
it's taken huge effort enormous efforts
a huge part of the economy is devoted to
trying to drive these things out of
people's heads to make you think that
all you want is more commodities so you
should go shopping instead of reading
principally this makes perfect sense as
it is far easier and more accessible to
attend to the more unconscious in a
vocable desires and thus more profitable
however easy does not mean helpful or
right for Nome Maslow and many others
the consequence of neglecting the higher
levels of human needs results in a void
of happiness value and purpose for all
involved an optimism supposed by the
likes of many great thinkers is that
capitalism can with proper time and
effort move up into the higher layers of
human needs on a mass scale sustaining
the value that consumerism has on a
society while not solely focusing on the
sale of trivial and superficial things
in a new age of an Internet and
attention based economy we perhaps have
the access and potential to satisfy this
goal unlike ever before with worldwide
real time social communication sharing
and perspective we can understand
genuine value and see through contrived
value far more easily with the Internet
the ability to sell or distribute
directly to the consumer is open to
essentially anyone and everyone in
theory this now means that the
individual can more easily sell create
and share things that perhaps wouldn't
otherwise be successful at a corporate
or mass retail level but own the
complete process and margin of a
product's profit and thus even at a
smaller scale still make a good living
when utilized this allows creators of
products services and artistic projects
to maintain creative control and
subsequently provide a more self-honest
reflects
of value to consumers moreover Chomsky
suggests that engaging in creative work
under one's own volition is an
imperative and fundamental part of our
nature one's work is sort of the core of
one's existence you want to be involved
in creative honest work in association
with others but voluntary Association
and not under external control which is
to say that after a certain point of
satisfying ones lower needs the act of
working and creating within the realm of
one's own creative interest is in fact
one of if not the highest reward of
working we have an opportunity to do
creative work under your own control
with especially if it has some social
purpose and so on and that's best thing
to do a lot better than you know lying
on a couch and watching a boring
television program by this account as
opposed to the vast majority of
purchasable products that we often see
as the reward of working a much greater
and higher level reward is somewhat
paradoxically found in the experience of
working itself a carrying out of our
full potential through work we deem
meaningful and valuable again as a
result of the internet this is arguably
available now more than any other time
in recent history there are very clear
signs of this shift towards more
meaningful and higher level
direct-to-consumer business and creative
independence taking place right now for
example the use of social media
platforms to share education art and
meaningful entertainment from individual
creators apps and websites that are
greatly helpful in dealing with mental
health physical health self education
and skill development that would perhaps
otherwise not be very accessible or
lucrative there are individuals making
and distributing films shows literature
music and so on entirely independent and
direct to an audience with no corporate
influence that might otherwise strip the
creative project of all its nuance in
order to appeal to the widest possible
audience if the internet of course also
has the potential to be used in the
opposite capacity selling more of the
same to more people through easier and
more intrusive ly manipulative advert
there are huge groups of people
information and markets around this
endeavor of using Internet platforms and
methods to exploit the lower levels of
our desires more easily and more
lucrative ly like any cultural
phenomenon the Internet has the ability
to compound the good and the bad within
our nature regardless of who we are as
individuals either selling or being sold
to perhaps we don't need more of the
same perhaps we don't need to use the
internet to sell cheap products in more
clever ways and perhaps we don't need to
figure out how to exploit social medias
to persist the same cycle of cat and
mouse between business and consumer
rather we far more likely need a
shifting of focus towards creating
things that are perhaps hard to make but
more meaningful to sell and buy there is
certainly a difficult amount of
self-honesty and introspection required
and figuring out where the line is truly
drawn in terms of what we want in this
life and how much furthermore there is a
certain amount of respectable discipline
also required in holding ourselves
accountable to it however in this
pursuit there is great dignity meaning
and character to be found and sustained
there's great opportunity to make room
for our higher selves regardless of how
or where we work and make our money we
should remember the fragility shortness
and deeply challenging conditions of
this life and make it our number-one
priority to at the very least not make
it any harder or more convoluted for
ourselves and others the world doesn't
need us to make the world any harder
than it already is rather the world
needs us pursuing our highest potential
resisting anything that might try to
take us from it and trying our best to
say and do things that are honest and
meaningful and that might help others do
the same the Internet is not and does
not need to be the single means in which
we strive towards this for many it is
not accessible or of interest however
arguably in all areas of work and
creativity the same principle applies
the point in regards to the Internet is
simply to illuminate how its recent
historical development provides a
potentially more accessible method
admittedly all of the aforementioned is
much easier said than done given the
current conditions of the world
unfortunately not everyone is given fair
opportunity and many face grave
challenges and limitations furthermore
even in the best of circumstances
finding success in anything personally
and socially meaningful is extremely
difficult temptations and distractions
hover above us at all times and those
who might find disdain in any of the
ideas shared thus far of whom will
likely continue to exploit consumers
temptations who will persist in this
world on the same course for good or for
bad out of intention or unawareness
realistically we can't expect that the
nature of corporations and the powers
that be will change all that much in the
near future nor can we expect that
business and advertisers will always
operate with the consumer as a human
being in mind however we can recognize
this truth and try to consume with the
corresponding skepticism while also
working our hardest to find and share
our highest self in spite of it all
regardless of how hard or far-off all
worthwhile goals and ideas reside in the
realm of grave challenge just far enough
out of reach to seem unlikely but just
close enough to be possible at the risk
of overly ambitious optimism perhaps if
properly leveraged by time culture and
the Internet there's a future where this
can be a little bit easier a future
where the things we are sold are a
little bit more helpful the way we are
sold them a little less annoying and
life in general is a little bit better
[Music]